hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to go home you drunk game
made in 15 hours about a drunken idiot
trying to stumble his way back home and
I looked at that and went hey that was
me
that's what I did after five nights at
[ __ ] boys drunk and drunk minecraft I
stumbled my way back home but not to my
wife and kids because I don't have those
as far as you know King why anyway I
loaded this game up and tried it to see
if it was any fun and it is but it's
also very hard because you practically
are a zombie as you're walking down this
alleyway and for some reason you just
you die basically you just die and
that's what its gonna be over and over
again so bear with me everybody come on
come on come off a whoa well it's nice
that you're going to the beat okay what
even happened home you [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] alright no left left left Oh oh
[ __ ] no box oh this sucks what am I
supposed to do
Todd you piece of [ __ ] oh ah it's like
no control oh good now the obstacles
aren't in my way I wonder what else is
I'm just gonna fall over like it idiot
come on come on come on okay stumble
stumble stumble eyeball there's nothing
I can do it's some [ __ ] [ __ ]
right here
just fell over
it's like QWOP but not QWOP it's even
harder than co-op because least co-op
was logical based on physics oh I wanna
do some jump oh oh why am I missing
something here
sir son is there some hidden control
scheme that I miss oh yeah oh oh that's
correct
I'm pretty sure that's he said [ __ ] the
wife and kids I'm going back to the club
baby oh yeah oh and now he's dead on
accident okay never mind that I thought
I actually was gonna do something there
but apparently not hooray I'm trying to
get the feel for this game but you gotta
bear with me it's not exactly easy just
bear with me I'm it was so obvious I
need to be drunk to play this obviously
but I'm not gonna have time for this
small adjustments small small small
small small don't matter small matters
not it gonna die hey I'm a drunk man I
didn't even push a button there I'm
pushing forward it's funny ha I'm
pushing forward and I'm going backwards
it's really funny how that is that way
nope no I'm going backwards cuz my
finger is on the W key
it's like this game just not supposed to
work because I'm really trying here I'm
really trying I want to win okay
straight straight narrow this is there's
a back way out there there's a back way
up there man you gotta you gotta watch
out for the bag the bag the bag the bag
the bag bags bag the bag the fence
events fence fence the bag thank you
thank you thank the bag the bag oh yeah
oh oh one making it hush [ __ ] I didn't
even get to enjoy it bag bag bag bag bag
bag bag fence fence fans can can hand
box I didn't call out the paper
obviously who's got up on the frickin
paper bleep I'm so drunk
I'm well you'd be okay I just wanna wear
hand I don't even want to win I just
want to get far and consistently to the
point where I understand why go right
I'm pushing left do you see how I push
left do you see I push right now do you
see how oh oh oh oh I gotta hold it down
oh I'm done then ah well shed my face my
ass what the hell oh you weren't even
nearer you didn't even touch it okay so
far so good
except for that except this Oh goddamn
gave this goddamn game I hate this game
very much so
I've all games follow the straight and
narrow
oh wow that worked I can't believe it
worked okay just one more obstacle in
front of you just one more oh oh you had
a ride I'm so happy right now
I'm so happy and free why I wish I could
do this for a long time long well I'm in
high school never gonna get home and see
my wife and kids again this is gonna
leave me because I'm just a damn drug
I'm never gonna be able to make home
actually I'm pretty sure I'm still a
zombie so there's probably no way that
uh I gotta put myself in the mind of
someone who's very drunk
bro you damn kids somehow I'm Sarah okay
gurgled I'm Kurt what is there some
fundamental principle of this game that
I'm not understanding or is it really
just well that's not normal but I'm
gonna go with it I will allow it
Bob cool oh [ __ ] whoa okay oh come on
back come on come on no no no what do
you I why why I want to know why I'd
like to think I've been drunk a few
times in my life and one I've never
stumbled this bad and two I've never
been able to do flips like that
he must be on a different level of drunk
I've never sold ah [ __ ] it I'm done
[ __ ] you Jesus Christmas piss potatoes
okay I'm done my score is 17 if you guys
can beat that hey good for you you you
did it I applaud you you're better than
me here's your official you're better
than markiplier thing an old cheeto
congratulations winner of this you are
the greatest in the history of the
internet so thanks again everybody so
much for watching and remember you can
check out other stupid angry min deucing
videos that I've done in the past in the
description flower in the annotation so
thanks again everybody for watching
don't go drinking kids it's just
terrible you'll end up like this and as
always now we'll see you in the next
video bye bye
Oh
possible